community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
it is a new year in findlay automotive
the sponsors of this next segment shows
no slide wow let me just start that and
roll this back i'm going to pretend that
didn't even happen hey it's a new year
welcome back and findlay automotive
group the sponsors of this next segment
shows no slowing down of their
philanthropic efforts welcome tyler
quarter to the show that was a rough
start but it's good to have you here
it's all good so you guys have done so
much in the community when it comes to
philanthropy in fact last year you won
champion of the year for your work with
best buddies right yeah we did and so
that was uh that was a fun thing what
you know we have a young gal by the name
of michelle that works for us at finley
toyota with came to us through best
buddies which provides opportunities for
people with
developmental and intellectual
disabilities wanted me to run for
champion of the year so we got the team
together it's a fundraising competition
we won the national fundraising
competition we raised more money than
anybody has ever raised for best place
you raised 231 thousand dollars and so
we were crowned best buddies champion of
the year so that was just one of the fun
things we did on the philanthropic end
last year such a great organization too
and they do so much good and
congratulations on that
in addition to that uh near and dear to
my heart also is make a wish and you
raise uh what was it 231 thousand
dollars well that was for best buddies
that was 331 000 and make a wish we did
we've been doing make-a-wish uh granting
wishes for uh quite some time and last
year we did a couple of really cool ones
with some vehicle makeovers uh an el
camino for a young man named jc and a
and a vehicle for a gustavo these young
people that have these very severe
diseases and mental uh medical problems
but we did a make-a-wish for them and
granted their wishes so that was a fun
thing to do we really like to do stuff
that's other than just giving checks
yeah although we did you know we counted
up we're at the end of the year we're
looking at last year we gave away all
about a million five uh in donations and
sponsorships to nonprofits and we do
that through our from our corporate
office but also all 33 of our dealership
locations have their own causes that
they're supporting so as we've grown and
gotten bigger and we're able to do more
and more for the community and that's
one of our corporate philosophies is we
want to support the community so last
year was a record year for us and what
we did for the community we're kind of
looking at what do we do this year to
try to we want to match that and do even
better this year well there's no
question in my mind that you guys will
because you have been so involved for so
long you also gave away in addition to
the funds a truck to spread the word and
we had partners on that but we gave a
truck to spread the word which is one of
our favorite charities which also gives
us volunteer opportunities and
we'd love to get our employees involved
they like to do things and so we were
out volunteering with the thing called
breakfast for books with spread the word
went out to st jude's ranch we had a
couple of volunteer things there we've
done a telethon for for three square we
find that our employees really like to
get engaged to get involved so we try to
provide volunteer opportunities on top
of the other things that we're doing in
the community this has been going on
since 1961. yep since 1961 i got
pictures of pete finley back in the 60s
donating to charities so we love to
carry on that tradition so what you
talked about this year looking forward
what are some of the things you guys are
eyeing well so there's a lot of
charities that we've been involved with
in the past and we'll
we'll re-up those but we're always
looking for things that we feel can make
a difference one a cool thing that we've
been doing is we created a automotive
technician training school for
vocational training through foundation
for independent tomorrow
a lot of jobs aren't going to come back
on the strip and so forth we need to
retrain people into jobs where they can
feed their family and so that's one of
the things that we're really going to
support is vocational training to help
people get back to work good folks over
at fit so yes absolutely appreciate
sincerely all you do in the community it
means so much so tyler thanks for
joining us thank you it's great to be
here appreciate it